facing the Mediterranean the city of
Zeus used to welcome its fair share of
tourists but numbers of foreigners have
dwindled in the past few years combined
with the rising cost of living tunisians
are struggling and some blame the state
before the pandemic work was good they
were tourists we used to employ three or
four people everyone was happy business
was good and everything was available
but now there is no work and everything
is expensive in one of the city's
markets both vendors and Shoppers have
noticed a rise in the cost of almost all
food items
only once a month the state is to blame
for all of this it is out of control
analysts say the government has made
mistakes in recent years and now the
economy is struggling as a result we
have a deep recession or stagnation of
the economy we have lost tens of
thousands of of companies we have lost
thousands of jobs also and in spite of
all that we have high inflation
this economist doesn't think the vote
will change anything
we know that most political parties are
boycotting those elections they are
considering that they don't mean
anything in fact and when we read the
Constitution we see that the parliament
is going to have very limited powers
almost unexisting Powers so why why go
through this process
politics is far from the minds of many
tunisians they're more worried about how
to afford the next meal
Al Jazeera